الى موضوع طبي جدلي والذي اثير مجددا بعد
وفاه وديع نجل الفنان جورج وسوف بعد اجراه
عمليات جراحه تكميم للمعدات حيث عاده
تتساؤلات عن مخاطرها وتداعيتها الجانبيه
على صحه الانسان عاده ما يلجا لهذه
العمليه الاشخاص ممن حاولوا ينقص وزنهم
بالطرق التقليديه مرارا لكن لم يوفقوا ذلك
لكنها تظل في النهايه عمليه جراحيه قد
يكون لها اعراض جانبيه ومخاطر تصل حد
الوفاه فهل يستدعي حلم الرشاقه الذي يراود
كثيرين ان يقوموا بمثل هذه العمليات خاصه
ان من تعرض لخطر او توفوا من مشاهير
بسببها اجره هذه العمليات على يدي كبار
الاطباء
[موسيقى]
ابدا معك يا دكتور لماذا تؤيد اجراء عمليه
تكميم المعده رغم حاله الوفاه الكثيره
التي سمعناها من اشخاص اجروا هذه العمليه
اولا احنا بنقدم محر التعازي للفنان جورج
وسوف في وفاه نجله
احنا خلينا نتكلم الموضوع مش مش بصفه ان
انا مع او ضد خلينا نتكلم الموضوع انجينال
او على العموم انه همم ما فيش تعارض ما
بين العمليات الجراحيه والتغذيه العلاجيه
او او انه العيان يعمل رجيم او خلاف
بالعكس احنا بنبدا مع العيان اولا انه
حضرتك دلوقت همم احنا قررنا اجراء عمليه
جراحيه بس دي لها شروط الشروط المعاينه دي
بتبدا اولا بعد فشل همم الاجراء الاحترازي
اللي هو ال- همم التغذيه العلاجيه او
برامج ريجيم المعينه ساعتها بنختار ان
احنا خلاص لازم العيان يتخلص من هذه
المشكله عن طريق اجراء عمليه
فطبعا لا يوجد تعارض ما بين ال- التغذيه
العلاجيه او او البرامج العلاجيه والعمليه
احنا بنرجع للعمليه بعد فشل جميع الطرق
الاحترازيه زي
التنظيم الغذائي او البرامج الغذائيه
المعينه طب هتطلع البرامج الغذائيه توجه
الى ريد تاخذ سيات اخصائيات تغذيه ريتا
لماذا انت معارضه لعمليات تكميم المعده
رغم بعد الفوائد الطبيه التي يتم حديث
عنها
الكلبساطه نحنا انا بامن انه من خلال
الاكل ومن خلال الرياضه ومن خلال تغيير
نمط الحياه تبع الشخص بيقدر هو ينزل وزنه
وهذا الشيء على المدى الطويل لان اليوم
العمليه بتوصلك بعد سنه سنتين انك تخسري
وزن محدد بس بعدين على الشخص انه يرجع
يحسنط حياته الاكل اول شيء هو دواء بس
كثير ناس ما بتامن انه في اشياء مسموح لها
وفي اشياء ممنوعه لها علاقه فلهذا السبب
بيضل له انه انا اي دايت بدي اعمل اي دايت
الاحسن لالي بالفعل انه اليوم احنا اذا
بنوقف ناكل فئه معاينه من الاكل لانه ما
بتناسب جسمنا احنا راح نشوف انه الوزن
تبعنا عم بينزل بلس قصه النمط الحياه كثير
ناس بتحط او اولويه شغله اولاويه همم
الحياه الاجتماعيه تبع همم التعصيب ستريس
وبتهمه صحتها ما بتحطها بالمركز الاول
وهذا الشيء بيخلي هرمونات
حتى لو ما اكلنا فمنها الممتلئ في كثير
ناس اذا راحوا عند بسيكولوج اذا راحوا عند
يمكن مرشد روحي ساعدوا انه هو هن يخففوا
هيدا ستراس او ينظم حياتهم بطريقه انه
يعطوا وقت لصحتهم تيقدروا يعملوا رياضه
تيقدروا ياكلوا صح بعتقد انه هيدا شيء على
المدى الطويل كفتره حياه بيقدروا يوصلوا
لنا نتيجه كثير احسن من قصه تصغير المعده
اللي هي بتوصلك لمرحله معينه وانا بالعيد
كثير بيعملوا همم عمليات وبيرجع بشوفهم
بعد سنه بعد سنتين بيقولوا ياريت عم بيرجع
انصح اريد توقف وزني ما بقى عم بضعف طب شو
لازم
اعملدائيه طبعا النظام الاكل ماشيين فيه
يعني انه ما ياكلوا حلو يخففه من كميه
النشويات لانه كل الجسم عنده كميه معينه
من الاكل قدر يحرقها بس اذا انت ما تعلمت
اليوم كيف لازم تاكلي كميه اللي بيحقق لك
اياها بالنهار والنواعيد الاكل لان انت
بتناسب جسمك مش ممكن حتى لو عملت العمليه
تضلك عم تقدري تضعفي